-Everyone's still talking
about Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And -- Yeah, why not?
I know. We love them both,
but their relationship
has united
two groups
that don't normally hang out --
Taylor Swift fans and NFL fans.
Well, we wanted to test
their knowledge of each other,
so we went down to 30 Rock Plaza
this afternoon
and asked dads
and their daughters
about Taylor and Travis.
One catch -- the daughters
could only answer questions
about Travis,
and the dads could only
answer questions about Taylor.
This is Swap Quiz.
-♪ "Tonight Show" Swap Quiz,
"Tonight Show" Swap Quiz ♪
-What is the title of
Taylor Swift's first album?
-"Tim McGraw."
-"1985."
-"1989"?
-No!
-"Taylor Swift."
-Yes.
-What team does Travis Kelce
play for?
-Kentucky Chiefs.
-Who is the quarterback
on Travis' team?
-Jonathan Morris.
-Gage Gatlinburg.
-Patrick Mahomes.
-Finish the song title.
"Look What You..."
-"Have Done to Me."
"Recently."
-"Back to..."
-"The Future."
-Daddy!
-What position
does Travis play?
-Tight end.
-What number is Travis Kelce?
-87.
Finish this song title.
"Cruel..."
-"Intentions."
-"Cruel..."
-Finish the lyric.
"'Cause, baby, now we got..."
-"Back from downtown."
-"Each other."
-What is Taylor Swift's
middle name?
-Charlotte.
-I don't know, but I know
that it's not Charlotte.
-Can you sing the song
"You Need to Calm Down"?
♪ You need to calm down ♪
♪ Down, down ♪
[ Laughs ]
-"We are never, ever, ever..."
-"Going to live again."
-[ Laughs ] What?! What?!
Oh! Thank you, everybody,
for playing.